des vaches qui semble nous regarder
comme habité d'un esprit supra naturel
c'est presque la vérité puisque nous
nous trouvons dans une ferme du berry
que l'on dit ensorcelait voilà une perte
aussi cultivatrice logicien au moins
depuis plusieurs années et ce par des
phénomènes curieux parmi le bétail
malheureusement ça se passe bien des
choses mais c'est toujours le même et
que se passe-t-il exactement bien écouté
dans les bêtes on a eu vraiment la
mortalité ma part ça peut encore y aller
parce que ça c'est pour encore aussi
terrible que dans notre laitages alors
notre laitages ont trait les vaches
ils ont dû les normalement mais il n'y a
absolument pas de mathias vous pouvez
pas faire de peur vous avez des
précautions vous avez demandé aux
vétérinaires par exemple oh oui monsieur
l'avenir et même plusieurs vétérinaires
mais il n'y a pas un qui s'y connaît
dans choses là et le terrain l'herbe est
ce que mangent les animaux on a fait un
analyse et l'herbe on à faire dans les
allées le sens de bétail il n'a tout
absolument rien d'anormal alors eh bien
cher monsieur je ne sais pas vous savez
on cherche mais lequel car si réellement
on peut trouver quelqu'un qui s'y
connaît ce qui passe nous délivre de ce
mal à face à ferrer les malentendus le
remède à cette calamité inexplicable la
fermière nous l'a demandé c'est un
sorcier
ni plus ni moins capable de soulever le
sort qui terrasse le bétail depuis huit
ans si nous sommes incapables de magie
nous a été pourtant possible de le
trouver ce bon sorcier
monsieur vous est ce qu'on appelle dans
la région persie mieux c'est à dire que
vous soignez les gens les bêtes et que
vous soulevez les mauvais sort est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner des exemples
où vous avez dû exercer ce curieux
métier oui moi ce curieux sacerdoce les
exemples de bêtes de jean soigner de
mauvais sort que vous avez vous avez
contre et plusieurs amis s'y joignent à
l'homme ça et comment ça arrive
d'habitude on vient vous chercher à la
jumelle ici et les bêtes vous soigner
les bêtes malades de guérisseur de bêtes
malades les deux jean est bien souvent
le vétérinaire les médecins ne
comprennent pas comment c'est arrivé
comme on n'avait pas déployé comme
fragile ce mois j'ai 19 ans je sais bien
que l'on pourra d'être de pierre la
plurielle du tout et c'est rapide
demain c'est rapide aux oyats lu au
journal qu'il y appelait à plus et après
la digestion les folies syndicales au
bout d'une demi-heure fini elle pourrait
changer ses plans
au delà de mieux à l'après mais ce qu'il
arrive souvent qu'on vienne vous dirons
nous acheter un mauvais sort les bêtes
sont malades
l'aide arrive quand même nous avait
raconté tout à l'heure une histoire dans
une ferme quelqu'un avait jeté un sort
comme ça
comment ça s'est passé
sur l'ajoie au léman j ai été piégé je
suis valérie et le plus chez lui c'est
la date ou nirvana et qu'est ce que vous
avez fait spéciale une prière spéciale
c'est pas une vie ordinaire
et puis qu'est ce qu'il est arrivé où je
tort de ça il était mal à monsieur paul
s'il avait fait ça peut dire s'il y
avait déjà le support du 10 mai vous
savez ce qu'il avait pensé parce que
vous aviez aussi zahia ne vais rigoler
c'est vous qui avez retourné le sort
contre lui a valu dial est chez lui
devant les caméras le père signoli les
prières naïve qui lui servent à guérir
bétail est gentil même n'importe quel
vétérinaire vous dira qu'on appelle le
sorcier avant lui dans 80% des cas
[Musique]
les médecins du berry sont moins
catégoriques mais ils viennent bien
souvent après que les remèdes surnaturel
et échoué quant aux jouteurs de sorts et
autres fabricants de maléfices nous
n'avons pas pu les rencontrer
et pour cause
[Musique]